his roster Tucker with us there fritzy
standby all right no always good to have
our good friend Ross Tucker Westwood one
NBC serious radio he's got a lot of jobs
here Ross how are you dad I'm good I
just I heard the other day that I
thought the uber driver was gonna maybe
take you down more yeah it's not very
often you get into a cab and the uber
driver goes you smell good tonight
you smell like meat and then he then I
didn't hear the start I thought he
picked you up right after the show on
like a meat Friday
no no one to meet Friday I was leaving
an Adam Sandler post party the premiere
post party and I didn't have any meat
there but I got into me I got into the
uber and he goes you smell good tonight
you smell like meat and then he followed
that up by saying I'm not very good at
directions so didn't feel that confident
there with him you don't know where he's
going and he thinks I smell like meat
what could go wrong Ross right you know
I almost pulled over I was laughing so
hard it's amazing I want you to tell me
what you think of this
we just had Barry Trammell on and he is
a columnist for The Oklahoman he covered
Baker Mayfield in college and he says
that Baker doesn't want to be Eli
Manning he wants to be Joe Namath what
are you making that quote yeah that
would really scare me because what does
that really mean where does that really
imply it means what we're talking really
about the auspice field stuff in my mind
man more than the on the field stuff so
he aspires to be the type of guy that is
known for you know late-night partying
and you know being with a lot of women I
mean not that there's anything wrong
with that and but if I'm taking somebody
with a normal overall pick that was
scary
and everything I said a lot like the
picture we put up about Brett Favre is
awesome that picture that he did that
took a lot of time to get that picture
exactly perfect so he is the time for
that and the docu-series but he didn't
have the time to look at the Chargers
playbook I just I got a lot of questions
there I mean I
other stuff during the pre-draft process
trying to get him on radio shows I just
there would be a lot of concerns there
for me taking him I'm a conservative
person and that the maturity risk is too
much for me I would not take Baker
Mayfield do you think that these tweets
that have resurfaced with Josh Allen
from 2012-2013 will affect his draft
status I don't think a lot I guess the
only question you would have as a team
isn't really in my mind about Josh Allen
or if he's raised this or any of that
stuff I think that the question would be
what will the impact of this be in our
market you know amongst our fans and in
the locker room you know what will your
reaction be when because this will be
the big story I said a giraffe in the
night this will be the big story that
head they draft this guy who had these
tweets and so you immediately have some
percentage of your fan base that already
is skeptical of the guy just starting
out so if it's tied between Josh Allen
and Josh Rosen on your board or Josh
Allen and sam Donald is that a little
tiny thing that can tip it in your favor
or against Josh Allen I don't know I I
don't know that would react in Locker I
know that the Riley Cooper saying to not
go over real well and Philadelphia
obviously a lot of different Riley
Cooper was already a member of the team
he wasn't whatever Josh Allen was 15 or
16 in high school I assume there's
another interesting part of that then
which is that Brooke whatever Josh Allen
did people saying he was quoting a movie
or I don't know I don't know about that
I know it was not smart to tweet that
but I just wonder who is the adult that
waits till the morning of the draft and
that's for the draft to leak that stuff
you're doing it to intentionally harm
him and maybe it takes almost well that
ends well you know whatever it takes to
try to get the kid to drop to you I
don't know but I were to have a tough
time doing that even if it's kind of an
by any means necessary thing I'd have a
tough time doing that to intentionally
hurt it's like all the stuff with Darius
guys coming out now or late in van der
ass
with the neck I talked to him yesterday
you know just seeing these 20 year old
guys in person I'm here in Dallas and
just just seeing how upset Darius guys
and band arash were by this stuff coming
out that could hurt their draft standing
I hope the people that do it and leaked
it intentionally really really feel good
about themselves talking to Ross Tucker
joining us from Dallas of course the
draft coming up tonight let me go back
to the LSU running back Darius Kaiser he
I don't know what kind of personality he
has but he said some things that he was
he was asked certain questions at the
combine like does he like men and so he
brought this up and then teams have said
no no one asked him that right what is
going on with this kid because he's you
know first-round Talent I'm guessing
it's certainly a second-round Talent and
has a chance to you know have a good
career here I don't know if he's
sabotaging himself here yeah he's a
really outgoing kid he's got a great
personality he's fun to talk to and I
wonder if either two things happened in
my mind and number one he either just
kind of you know whatever radio show he
was on they were liking what he was
saying and they were laughing and he
just kind of was getting excited and
they exaggerated a story to them either
that I think it might be option number
two Dan which is that someone made it
very clear to him it's not good that
your name's associated with this and if
a team gets in trouble for this that's
really bad for you you need to tell
people that this never happened I wonder
if he got the you know got the memo from
some people that are in the know or some
people in the NFL hey we can't have this
right now we can't have you saying that
this happened this will be real bad for
you you need to just tell NFL security
when they call you that you were just
exaggerating and it didn't really happen
because you know why would he make that
up then I mean that that's a strange
thing to just say or just to make up on
a radio show like who would do that yeah
I was trying to figure that out if he
was just trying to be funny and you know
be a little colorful there and then all
of a sudden somebody says well wait a
minute was that true you know
I don't know I don't know I know I'm
sure how to answer this and then it just
felt like you know you don't want to be
labeled as a snitch here and you know
maybe other if he gets drafted then guys
are gonna think that they're
management's gonna think he's gonna tell
or players think he's gonna tell
something so I don't know I just was
sort of fascinated by that didn't want
to ask you this you're if you're the
Browns but the number one thing you do
what oh I take say I'm darn old and it's
not even close I think he's clearly the
best quarterback Dan I mean I just I met
him at the US Army Bowl for NBC three
years ago was incredibly impressed by
him on a bunch of different levels and
I'm risk-averse Dan you know I the Baker
Mayfield maturity concerns I don't want
that I don't want the Josh Allen
accuracy and also he's slow to process
information when you watch them on tape
and then you get to Josh Rosen he's got
the most risk in my mind I mean number
one he had two concussions last year
we're talking about a guy whose mom went
to Princeton dad went to Penn that would
concern me maybe gets a third concussion
in less than a year I don't know if I'd
be playing if I got three concussions in
less than a year but alone his coach was
made it very clear that football is not
always this priority his college coach
and then you've got the same maturity
concerns with him I met the decision
making to wear a hat that has the S word
on it let alone about someone in
politics I just my mind is blown that he
was already UCLA's quarterback and the
pro prospect and that he thought it was
a good idea to do that so there are
three negatives in my mind for Josh
Rosen the only negative for Donald is
the fumbles and I think that that's just
hey he hasn't played that much two hands
on the ball I think he'll be okay
thank you Ron so we always appreciate
your time and good luck tonight
Thanks that's Ross Tucker former NFL
lineman working for Westwood One NBC
Sports Network and serious for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]